The Body of dorsomia Lies in her modest
home a relative packs a bag with things
she'll need for her journey to the
afterlife
her son watches without emotion as the
funeral rights proceed
she died after being hit by an artillery
shell in a shelter close to the fields
where she worked the shell didn't
explode but she bled to death after it
hit her in the thigh
the ground was shaking and my child was
crying the woman shattered unhet
unhatched in light as she died
this Primary School in the same Village
was hit two months ago killing a
five-year-old girl and enduring eight
others walls pockmarked with shrapnel
and a hole left by a direct hit suggests
the school was intentionally targeted by
myanmar's military
in a nearby Clinic a young boy winces
with pain injured in a traffic accident
the doctor tries to patch him up but
aside from stitching and cleaning the
wound there's very little that can be
done
medical supplies are scarce
the military government's practice is
that they cut food and medicine to the
area when there is fighting we have to
connect with local resistant groups to
solve these problems even places of
worship aren't safe villagers say this
church was burned down by the Army in
the summer but no one can get in to
rebuild or repair because the area is
heavily mined it's a tactic the military
uses frequently
there are many landmines we retrieve
more than 700 landmines from John Dar
Village which the enemy has planned it
they use it as protection when they are
weak we have lost many lives lakes and
armed to land mines we have suffered
more because of Minds than in battle
back in the village the body of
dorsomyar is ready to be buried
according to local tradition her
possessions are burned
as mourner's whale her coffin is nailed
shut
and lowered into the ground
another civilian victim of the army that
was supposed to protect her
Tony Chang Al jazura